Hey Kunal, what are you doing?
>> I just need a minute.
>> What you writing.
>> Well,
why are you looking at my email?
>> I just want to see what you doing.
>> Okay fine.
I'm sending an email to a friend to-
>> Okay.
>> Which has instructions
on how to feed Chloe.
>> Who's Chloe?
>> Chloe's my office plant.
You name your office plant Chloe?
>> Yeah, Chloe for chlorophyll.
>> Clever.
[LAUGH]
>> Look, here it is.
>> Okay.
You know what this reminds me of?
>> What?
>> These instructions are similar
to how you write code to tell
a computer what to do.
>> Everything reminds you of how to
write instructions or code, Katherine.
[LAUGH]
>> It does.
But I'm serious.
This time it does, it's sort of like.
Like here, this line where
you're saying that you need to
water the plant exactly
on Tuesday at 10 o'clock.
>> Right, so when I'm giving specific
instructions on Tuesdays and
Thursdays water the plant.
Or make sure the water is lukewarm.
Those specific instructions
are like writing code.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> And you know how
you're writing this
letter in an email app?
>> Yeah I'm using Gmail.
>> Good choice.
We also need a space to write our code.
>> Sure.
>> And that space is called an IDE.
>> What does that stand for?
>> It stands for
Integrated Development Environment.
>> I am more confused after listening to
the full form of that acronym when I was
when I heard the acronym.
>> Well,
don't worry about what it stands for.
In Android, all you need to know is
that we're going to use Android Studio.
>> Is that on this computer?
That software?
>> Yeah, it's right here,
let me show you.
>> And this is what it looks like.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, I must admit that this
looks a little bit intimidating.
It has a lot of buttons on it.
>> It is, there's a lot of things
going on but we'll get there.
By the end of the course, the students
will know how to operate this.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, good.
>> Cool, so back to your letter.
>> Okay.
>> You know how you're using
English to write this letter?
>> Well that's a great observation.
I thought you said you were not reading
my email, but yes, I am using English.
>> Okay.
Well, we have to use a certain
language to talk to the computer,
to give it instructions.
>> What are we using?
>> We're going to start with XML.
You know, Katherine, you're a fan of
three lettered acronyms, it seems.
[LAUGHS].
First IDE, now XML.
What does XML stand for?
>> It stands for
Extensible Markup Language.
>> Extensible Markup Language?
What does Extensible ML do?
>> [LAUGHS]
>> It is a way to describe how your
Android app is going to look.
>> Okay.
>> So we can use it to build layouts.
>> Okay, so
where are you going to place things,
what things you're going
to place on the phone.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay, well there's a lot
going on in this video so
let's just do a quick recap.
We're talking about how writing
code is like writing instructions.
Really specific instructions.
>> Right.
We're also talking about how we need
a space in which to write that code.
>> And
that space will be Android Studio.
>> And we also identified the
programming language we will be using.
>> Which is XML.
>> So let's write our first line of XML.
>> Yeah.